um the ones that connect to a computer
can be more immersive
I really like the hold on take your time
take your time
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching a hot ones reunion special
brought to you by Diablo 4 the iconic
action RPG series returning on June 6th
and we're once again joined in the hot
seat by Marquez Brownlee for more than a
decade he's been YouTube's Tech
consiglieri with his channel MKBHD proud
to say I'm one of its 17 million
subscribers check out his podcast
waveform and he has a brand new sneaker
collaboration with Adams out as well the
model 251 Marquez Brownlee welcome back
to the show thank you again for having
me you know it's been almost five years
to the day since our OG hot ones
interview it was back in season six of
the show how if at all has your
relationship to hot sauce changed in
that time I meant to talk to you about
this okay before the show I remember you
asked like how are you with spicy food
and I didn't really have an answer
since that show I have become I mean
I've had a lot of hot sauce in the in
the fridge at work all over the place
I've become the spicy food guy somehow
so uh it's changed in a good way I think
this is this show has introduced me to a
world of spicy food we made you a
spiceman yeah yeah this is awesome
all right you ready to get started I am
[Music]
last time we did this
almost the Obama's assistant is the same
everything else is different
so I'm looking forward to
re-experiencing it but a little bit
different
also I didn't eat lunch yet so
so this is the perfect way to do it
mm-hmm
[Music]
so one of your philosophies on making
good videos that I really relate to is
the idea that the gadget or product
being reviewed should be the star of the
show which is really how I think about
each new guest on an episode of hot ones
how is that Insight steered the
trajectory of MKBHD and your approach to
being a host
you know it's funny it actually helps
um anytime you talk to a Creator or a
YouTuber you've probably talked to a lot
of them where like this concept of
burnout comes up yeah
and I just feel like the fact that I am
not constantly trying to make like if I
was a vlogger my own life would be the
subject and then you're trying to make
your own life exciting for the video
so it's nice that I am not the star of
the show I think over time I had to
realize that and so yeah it's just a
matter of finding cool new tech things
happening that's always happening and I
just got to point a camera at it which
is pretty sweet and I feel like you also
have this Balancing Act of like you you
have to either make a guest more
comfortable or let them fill the space
like I remember watching The Neil
deGrasse Tyson episode where he just
fills the room yeah that's what he does
and it's amazing but you have this
balancing act too
I like verde hot sauces now I'm thinking
about all the hot sauce we have in the
studio and that you get to add more are
we gonna get some of these you're gonna
get everything yes the studio crew is
gonna be humped about that so I know
that you're inundated with requests to
review products and earlier this year
made a vow to say yes to every pitch
email that hit your inbox can you give
us one highlight and one low light from
that 30-day experiment that was that was
so much fun I mean I my job at this
point is not just reviewing Tech but
filtering the inbox for what to say yes
to
and I think part of that means a lot of
stuff gets lost that people don't even
realize the absurd things that happen in
the inbox were like can you review this
scooter that goes 60 miles an hour can
you review this other thing so I just
said yes for for a month got a bunch of
weird stuff out of it
I think
highlight was that I was pleasantly
surprised by some of this stuff fully
knowing that like before I even got it I
was like I know I'm gonna hate this and
getting some of them trying to think of
a specific thing that we got but like
some of the weird earbuds we got which
were cheap and kind of a knockoff but
also sounded pretty good so it was
surprising just give me a new
appreciation for like I think I'm gonna
say yes to more things yeah not to this
is gonna the brands are gonna start if
you heard that Brands green light to
mkbhd's inbox not everything not
everything what's the weirdest thing
that got sent to you
the weirdest that's always a weird I
mean not often yeah the coffin might be
the weirdest thing and it's weird
because we really got used to it like we
got we got the coffin a month you know
into the series and it's been sitting
around in the studio and we've fully
gotten used to a coffin sitting in the
middle of the studio for months which is
probably the weirdest thing
foreign
[Music]
pepper
so far so good I like these I'm gonna
enjoy these while they're
nicely spicy that's what's kind of nice
about getting a second go around on hot
ones you know
there's no like the the fear and anxiety
of the unknown you know I know we're
gonna enjoy I know where this is going
I'm not gonna get overconfident but like
first half lunch second half we'll see
how it goes battle four exactly what's
your favorite car you've ever driven
under fifty thousand dollars
oh that's a tough price because I was
just talking about the ev6 GT which I
love but it's sixty thousand dollars
so my favorite car I've driven under 50.
I think that might go to that's a tough
one pole star might be 55. you can go 55
I'll give you a five grand leeway yeah I
really like the pole star
uh and the postar is just like the sort
of a mid-sized crossover hashback thing
super simple made by Volvo not too
flashy but just like a solid nice Eevee
and something you don't appreciate about
cars until you get to use a bunch of
them is their software across the board
sucks all of them bad so when they
actually have good software and you just
get to use it out the box and not worry
about connecting your phone that's kind
of rare what's something people tend to
over index when they're shopping for a
car and then is there something that you
think they don't think about enough
underappreciated is software because
it's either I'm connecting my phone via
Bluetooth or they just go straight to
carplay
and a lot of the ones that just go
straight to carplay you ignore like the
GPS built in the the radio built in all
those and they're usually terrible but
if they're good that could surprise you
and maybe you might use that
so maybe that's under indexed
um and then probably over indexes
performance it's just fun you don't
actually need a fast car but like come
on it's fun it's fun
it's a busy bottle yeah a lot going on
remember last time I reviewed the
the bottles oh I'm sort of doing that
yeah yeah
so one of the Staples of your channel
has been the studio tours and I know
that you're working steadily to build
out your ultimate content creation HQ is
there a detail in the new studio that
maybe people thought was ridiculous when
you were conceiving it but something
that you're really proud of one thing I
always point out even though no one
seems to care when I'd show it to them
is every room that we shoot video in
also needs to sound good and you don't
think about that until you're in a room
that sounds bad this room sounds good
and you look up and you see the
fiberglass and you see the the backdrop
we have here and all the things in the
room contribute to it sounding good so
uh the first thing we did in our new
spot because it was an echo chamber was
put a ton of foam in the ceiling it cost
us too much
but to have people come up and glue foam
to the entire ceiling and then put our
carpet down and that probably would look
ridiculous on an invoice sheet like why
did you buy that much foam but when you
walk into that room empty and clap you
would hear it I'm not exaggerating you
would hear that clap for seven seconds
and now it just sounds like us talking
in a room which is a massive Improvement
so looks crazy to buy a bunch of foam
but it works what was the most
jaw-dropping thing that you saw walking
through the Mr Beast campus
that's that that scale of operation is
amazing Jimmy's you got has he not been
on the show yet no not yet okay well
Jimmy
explain it to Sean for yourself please
um no I mean I'm the Gearhead so I
walked in the gear room and there was a
there's just these shelves and shelves
of cameras and batteries because what
they do is a little bit Next Level we
have a lot of cameras obviously but
they'll shoot a challenge with like a
hundred people doing something right all
100 people have a camera and a battery
and an SD card and a microphone and
suddenly there's just there's just this
wall of beer so it's like an old school
operator you know pulling uh this wire
out of this thing and there's a lot of
this yeah exactly and so the yeah they
have a lot and that means there's a lot
of chargers a lot of memory card readers
a lot of all that stuff how would you
grade the hot one Studio on a scale from
content creators Paradise to Total
[__] all right
let's see here
cameras pretty solid I mean this is the
thing about you walk into a studio you
never really know what to expect every
time I walk in The Sound Studio I'm
surprised by something yeah yeah yeah
um this is this is nice this sounds
excellent good sound I don't know if you
appreciate how quiet it is in here it is
there's no HVAC sounds you're in New
York City there's no helicopters that's
great we're in the void and then it gets
dark back here so you got this nice like
focused lighting I think I'm gonna give
it a good grade this is nice it's a nice
Studio well we'll take that we'll take
that you've made it on YouTube well if
Marcus Brownlee says it then you know
it's the truth are you ready to move on
here to the halfway point Calientes this
is Los Calientes Rojo
foreign
[Music]
still hitting yeah thus concludes the
lunge portion exactly of today's program
I suspected
so my apologies is I'm sure you get this
all the time in your real life but I
have like some tech pet peeves that I
kind of want to bounce off of you and
you might not even have a response to
this maybe I just need you as like a
shoulder to lean on but here's my thing
all right so in the decade plus since it
was introduced I feel like there has
been zero Improvement in Airplane Wi-Fi
which for the record cost
39.95 for a single cross-country flight
from New York to Los Angeles and vice
versa my question to you maybe you know
maybe you don't maybe you have a theory
but
the needle the tech needle to thread on
airplane Wi-Fi just so impossible or are
we all getting robbed in the air
a little bit of both
it's it's definitely I remember hearing
from like my parents about how when you
got on a long flight you would just sit
there and there was nothing to do and so
I can appreciate that at least there is
Wi-Fi but I'm with you
slow Wi-Fi is worse than no Wi-Fi at all
and I feel like if we vote with our
wallets yeah we start not using the
airlines that have awful Wi-Fi there we
go maybe maybe
they'll be incentivized to do a little
better the revolution starts today
[Music]
turn
kind of like it yeah it's not too I mean
it might hit me in a second but it kind
of grows on you okay that's fair yeah
you know
yeah it's one of those that has like you
said tarte up front and I agree with you
right yeah but then it's one of these
that kind of builds
like a wave a little little wave coming
on yeah we've been yeah yeah you know
very pepper forward sauce right there
feel it smoky smoky you know so I mean
this with all due respect but your most
impressive YouTube videos are the
ultimate frisbee highlights quick shout
out to the New York Empire your 2022
audl Champions thank you the pizza pie
throw all right is that you know is that
actually practical is that useful or is
that just for show-offs you're talking
about I'm assuming the sort of over the
top on the top but you're not really
gripping it you know that's pizza for
the beach you know that's a fun one in a
game you're a lot of people don't think
about this but you're throwing against
someone who's right in front of you
called the mark
uh so the most useful throws are far out
from your body or over the top of them
there's a lot of novelty fun throws on
the beach that aren't that so they
wouldn't work in a game but I appreciate
uh the reference what's the most
impressive trick shot you ever recall
Hitting off of the field
okay
so a long time ago
I did a YouTube Collide with Brodie
Smith yes yes uh who has done a ton of
trick shots really interesting ones and
he came out to our college campus this
is I was in college at the time and we
just took a whole day to shoot trick
shots and first thing I thought in my
head when shooting that video was like
how long does it really take this guy to
hit these trick shots and he's
incredible at it and the goal for the
video is for me to also hit trick shots
and
I was not incredible at it so it took me
a lot longer but I hit some crazy like
sort of 40 yard diagonal off of a roof
shot into a trash can that I felt pretty
good about
um I'll never be able to do that again
but that was my best trick shot it was
caught on video yeah yeah
I kind of like the the pepper the
jalapeno part of that one yeah which
comes through this one I feel like it's
a little sharper now but the other one
was kind of like Smoky you probably have
the best like description of like you
know how people will describe wine
because yeah right yeah you should have
the the shapes and the tones and
textures of hot sauce right right so
like this one a little bit more of a
razor cut a little bit more of a razor
cut sharp you know yeah yeah whereas
this one you know you're walking in a
room full of smoke you know Smoky sauna
is what we call this one okay this one a
little bit more uh razor blade a little
cut little cut action feel that
interesting okay I like that
what's the YouTube rabbit hole or
Channel besides your own that you've
binged the most in the last year
um
huh
lifetime probably Vsauce yeah Legend
um I've watched like every Vsauce video
and they're all long so probably hours
wise uh I've also watched a lot of
Schultz's podcasts
you're um flagrant yeah yeah those are
long those are long podcasts I feel like
yeah podcasts are probably the most
hours
um I do have my own podcast which is
like an hour long but there are some
like three hour podcasts that I watch on
YouTube so probably those there you go
do you get into any like off-peace
genres or like hyper-specific YouTube
genres like if you looked at my watch
History like basically it'd just be like
suspect interrogation videos and then
mini docs on like elderly people who are
in Romance scams like are you into
anything weird there YouTube has a way
of finding you like your homepage is
probably that specific every time and I
can't stop I can't stop I have gotten
into the exact same uh interrogation
video Rabbit Hole probably that you have
JCS baby there's a lot of them
um
mine right now is probably
so I've I've been watching a lot of car
videos and there's a lot of car videos
that are like 30 second intros made by
the salesman in the dealership
interesting which is a weird I don't
know how they get connected by the
YouTube Gods but they just keep
surfacing like a Porsche of Englewood
has a 30 second video about the 911
Carrera you should watch it you're not
gonna buy it just watch it so that's one
um so basically like YouTube car
classified ads basically yeah I don't
know how they connect these uh yeah that
was not even that weird but there are
not as weird as me
you've got some rabbits yeah I gotta I
should I need an evaluation
all right on the topic
here we are this next sauce here we are
[Music]
my old friend you know yeah
just as you remember it
yeah yeah
[Music]
here we are Sean well yeah bring you
back
yeah did I ever tell you that last time
no tell me about last last time after
the show
at uh summer league ultimate frisbee
right after what and that was
the worst part of my day
uh it just sits with you you know yeah
and then yeah
and the cramping that you can get with
something like this you know I wouldn't
even want to be in a line when that hits
and you're just like out on the field
yeah
running around
wow that went way worse than you
remember it yep
I know I know
you know you you get five years of
distance from it and you're like oh well
how bad can it be you know Rose Colored
Glasses and then yeah and then you get
face to face again
oh my God I know I know and it doesn't
stop and it doesn't stop do you have a
Mount Rushmore of tech CEOs
[Music]
um
not really oh my God
I think they're all uh most of them
actually my favorites are the product
people yeah because they get in the
weeds of the actual quality of the
product
but a lot of them are like steering a
large boat with many oars
so I can respect the
direction that they choose to steer the
boat but
there's a lot of people helping those
people out you know yeah
and like a product person like I've
heard you I've heard you make the
comparison that like Steve Jobs was like
a product guy right yeah but Tim Cook's
a little bit different yeah he's uh he's
the supply chain guy
which is cool that's like a great rank
you know that's how you become the CEO
is by making them a lot of money
being a very efficient
but I just like talking to product
people because I care about the products
you're a product guy exactly so
yeah I'm sure Tim's cool but
if you were CEO of YouTube for a day
like what would be your first course of
action like is there a feature you'd
bring back or one that you'd introduce
I'm really gonna look in backwards yeah
me too I would
I'd bring back the dislike counter yeah
I missed that the thumbs up thumbs down
it's useful but yeah I like that yeah
um you can't go back too far
but there was an old feature called
video responses
where if someone made a video response
to your video you could approve it
and it would show up right underneath
your video and
it was it was a neat like networking
feature where you know three cool people
made a video response to your video you
could have them right below
that was cool I bring that back too all
right Marquez
we're moving on already
peculiar okay it's a strange one
it's the reddest one it is it's the
reddest hot sauce yeah it's a Rudolph's
nose hot sauce
nothing can hurt me now the bomb already
got me
right
I'm fine yeah it's fine
just in times like these right
it is peculiar
so I remember and appreciate the pro
bono Consulting work that you did for me
when I was shopping for a camera what's
the most immersive VR experience you've
ever had because now I'm in that market
recently there's still like uh there's
still two types of VR there's the ones
that are standalone
and then there's the ones that are
connected to a computer
the Standalone ones are kind of limited
by the fact that they
need a battery and they need to be
lightweight
um the ones that connect to a computer
can be more immersive
I really like the
hold on
take your time take your time
I really like the
the PlayStation the psvr too
let's try that one
uh it's really it's good it's immersive
it's really virtual
all right Marquez
as we've established you're well versed
in the tradition of hot ones you're
probably wondering to yourself right now
where is the last app where is the last
app well I regret to inform you that we
are now face to face with a special
edition Diablo 4 sauce this one right
here Lilith's hatred
okay sure
in the game she's the Demonic mother of
humanity and co-creator of sanctuary
where Diablo 4 takes place she's also
known as the daughter of hatred and is
the big bad of Diablo 4. so it's safe to
say this sauce will be hell
but I think for tradition's sake we
should put a little on the last Wing
actually
all right there we go
so here we go
so Diablo 4 all about letting you play
your way from customizing your character
to exploring a totally open world here
on hot ones though there's only one way
to end
and it
it's not easy all right cheers Marcus
there we go
I know I know yeah I know yeah
okay Marquez Bromley to close things out
I love the way that you Andrew and David
break up the podcast with these trivia
mini games all right but you've never
had to take on these kinds of questions
with your brain marinating in hot sauce
so what I have here is a Tech quiz for
you a tech Pop Quiz multiple choice you
get two out of three of these right I'll
be blown away especially under these
conditions all right are you ready okay
all right question number one what was
the first computer virus to cause a
massive Global epidemic discovered in
1988 was it I love you Melissa virus
Morris worm or my Doom
dang
I'm really glad it's multiple choices
that's tough is it I love you
it is Morris worm Morris worm one down
we got two more we got two more we got
two more gotta be milk what was the name
of the first electronic general purpose
computer completed in 1945 univac one
IBM 701 eniac Colossus I just want you
to know I have no idea just take a swing
there's no way
I would know anything about that's why I
did retro Tech I don't know anything
about pre-2000
Tech
give me this one more time ready yeah
yeah univac one
IBM 701
eniac
Colossus
give me back one it was eniac it was
eniac one more for you not gonna work
for you and it's super easy what is the
name of the principal stating that is
impossible to perfectly replicate both
the position and momentum of a Quantum
particle simultaneously is that
Schrodinger's uncertainty principle
Heisenberg's uncertainty principle
Plank's uncertainty principle or duroc's
uncertainty principle
I want to get one of these right so this
is I gotta think about this one
more time sure are you ready yes yes I'm
listening carefully what is the name of
the principle stating that it is
impossible to perfectly replicate both
the position and momentum of a Quantum
party
Heisenberg's uncertainty principle
without even taking on the multiple
choice the answer is Heisenberg's
uncertainty principle thank you look at
you Marcus Brownlee for the second time
taking on the wings of death and living
to tell the tale now there's nothing
left to do but roll out the red carpet
for you this camera this camera this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life
I'm just I'm still making Tech YouTube
videos and I'm doing the same thing I
was doing five years ago just like you
I'll see you in another five years yeah
exactly this is uh this is real I'm glad
that the sauces are still pretty fair
catch me on YouTube I guess
[Applause]
[Music]
I feel like it's just the bomb
but no more you don't have any Ultimate
Frisbee practices no not today I I
didn't make the same mistake twice
foreign